Dust your floors the cutest way possible with
a fuzzy robot cleaning ball.
And protect your banana from bruising thanks
to the banana bunker.
Because it’s episode 52 of LÜT.
Skate through the day on the most advanced
electronic skateboard in the world.
The Marbel Board is controlled with an app,
reaches a top speed of 25 mph, and goes 16
miles before needing a recharge.
Use the app to set your speed and adjust the
rate of acceleration so once you hop on the
board there won’t be any surprises.
If you want a scientific surprise simply subscribe
to Groovy Lab in a Box.
A monthly collection of hands-on science fun
to promote STEM learning and tap into your
inner engineer.
Tap into a watermelon for some fruity beverage
dispensing fun using the Watermelon Keg.
And stay professionally dry in the water while
wearing The Quicksilver True Wetsuit.
The waterproof business suit comes in Black,
Navy, or Tuxedo, and is accompanied by a waterproof
shirt and tie.
Keep it business in the front while partying
in the back thanks to the Instant Mullet Headband.
Then start your own mechanical band with Mr.
Knocky the drumming robot.
Hold the drumsticks and start drumming and
Mr. Knocky will mimic your movements.
Don’t knock fishing until you’ve tried
it with the Fish Catching RC Boat.
That comes with pre-rigged tackle and it can
catch up to a 2 lb fish.
To help you catch some z’s there’s the
Wake Up Light Alarm Clock.
It lulls you to sleep with its sunset simulation
and gently wakes you with bird chirping and
the sun rise.
Arcade Resurrection allows pinball machines
to rise from the grave.
Altar Furniture completely tears down discarded
pinball cabinets and repurposes the artwork
and parts to create incredible tables.
Like Star Wars pinball becoming The Droid
coffee table or the 1987 game Arena transforming
into The Beast.
One of the beast ways to impress your friends
is turning objects invisible.
The invisibility kit is comprised of a series
of convex lenses and metal rods which can
remove small objects from sight.
Cite beer farmer on your list of accomplishments
after you grow everything you need with the
Grow Your Own Beer Garden.
They guarantee the plants will grow, and you
get to house it all in a see-through dome
MAKING IT THE BEER OF THE FUTURE.
Glide into the future with these sidewinding
circular skates - that give you the ability
to make sharp turns and perform tricks all
while sidewinding like a snake.
If butterflies are more your spirit animal
these butterfly keychains will speak your
language.
But if butterfly is the only language you
know the 15 language talking translator can
help you communicate.
And even includes a calculator for converting
Euros.
You're oh so going to love Movies R Fun, a
picture book that draws scenes from R rated
movies in a cartoony pixar style, including
classic moments from Pulp Fiction, The Godfather,
and my personal favorite - The Big Lewbowski.
Now you just need a rug to tie the room together,
like this latch-hook Lebowski.
Whether or not you like it is just like your
opinion, man.
BAR-O-SAURUS the fruit bar with a dinosaur
quiz.
Borrowing the amazing brick aesthetic of Lego
is the Lego Computer.
The specs are listed on the website, it’s
customizable and designed for future expansion.
And you can purchase one of three designs
industrial, brick, or tiled.
Tiled of letting other people build things
for you?
Design and program your own Hexapod Six.
You can 3D print a number of open source parts
for the robot, and even connect it to your
personal smartphone.
I’m afraid our time is coming to a close
so fill a personalized mason jar from personalcreations.com
with some Kimchi flavored soda.
And if you don’t like the taste don't worry
I won’t be offended.
In fact.
Zero fox given.
And as always - thanks for watching!